[Music]
hey what's up guys welcome back
it's mkbhd now I don't know if you guys
know this but before there was Facebook
before Google+ even existed before
social networking was popular the
biggest social network out there was
myspace now when you think of MySpace
what do you think of you probably think
of like a desert wasteland that only a
few people still use but MySpace is kind
of rolling back dare I say it they're
rolling out a pretty sweet-looking new
redesign yeah I said it
so there's actually something good about
MySpace now they're rolling out sort of
a metro UI looking redesign it kind of
reminds me of the new outlook comm and
actually roll out a video of it today so
you can check that out there's a link in
the description but to basically
summarize it it looks really slick
that's the word I'd use to describe this
new layout you have a horizontally
scrolling timeline and photo feed and
Friends list and a notification bar and
everything else important is at the
bottom instead of the top it's almost
like they're trying to be almost
Facebook but not quite but as you go
through the video you have to admit the
layout the general design the fonts the
styles the general user interface of the
new myspace well they actually look good
so basically what I guess I'm trying to
say is myspace is now actually a good
website it's not a good social network
anymore because no one really uses it
right now but it's a good website so
this particular change might not bring
me back to myspace but the designers did
a great job so thumbs up to them they
actually worked out a pretty
good-looking site now I'm not going to
sit here and tell you oh people use
MySpace there are actually a few people
who still use it and not by accident
video and music are really big part of
myspace right now and a lot of smaller
artists and like bands and things like
that host their music on MySpace kind of
like a Facebook page would today so it's
very apparent in the new myspace design
is you watch the video you notice that
media is very very center stage there's
a whole lot of music videos and you know
sort of integrated apps you can create
sort of radio stations of different
artists you're listening to and they
link back to their myspace profile so
overall they showed a lot of Justin
Timberlake because
well he pretty much is my space right
now and at the beginning of the video
did you catch that yep you can sign in
with Facebook nice and then the video
ends with a logo that looks strikingly
similar to another company that used to
be popular logo they changed it from
their old one to their new one and
there's also a link to request an invite
as if you have to like get in like
you're waiting online to get into my
space whatever I'm not going to judge so
the link if you actually want to go on
myspace right now actually visited it by
accident a couple of days ago before
this change happened but if you want to
request an invite if you're dying to get
into myspace right now with the new
version there's a link below to check
that out and maybe I'll see you now I'm
just kidding I want to see you over
there face
[Music]
you